ufc 264
real or not the old conor mcgregor is
gone forever dustin porter is a top
light heavyweight the ufc's 264 main
event only lasted one round but dustin
did plenty in his victory over counter
to prove he deserves the first
title shot at charles oliveira is per
year already the best liked way in the
world as for conor mcgregor the misstep
that caused a serious leg injury brought
the fight to an abrupt end
is an elite version of counter a thing
of the past
and where does he go from here kai can
you pull up a grover's uh
instagram post about about connor
everybody must read this
uh by the way shout out to tim he just
sent me three nice uh air jordan shoes
each one of them real sick like
michael's from his book just became a
new york times bestseller sick book if
you haven't ordered you ought to do it
okay
when when conor mcgregor lost to khabib
he was exposed by the limelight and has
never found his way back to the true
darkness that had
allowed him to win winning one except
this version of counter because this
connor still thinks
and acts like he's winning and winning
knows he is not let me read that one
more time winning won't
accept this version of counter because
this counter still
thinks and acts like he's winning and
winning knows he's not this loss to
dustin is about so much more
than an injury if you've read winning
you get this he hasn't taken that
necessary bus ride back to hell
winners know that in order to repeat
they have to get on that bus
along with all their demons and monsters
and skeletons asking
now what conor can't answer them because
that bus ride needs to be taken in
silence
winning requires real talk or no talk at
all the only thing you hear
are the silencing of your heartbeat and
the shortening of your breath as you
you approach hell you have no choice you
can either commit
to taking the bus ride to hell and fight
your way back to winning
or hell will come for you anyway snatch
your heart out of your chest
and make you watch it stop as you take
your last breath
and you lose forever that's the
difference between taking yourself to
hell
and health taking you one you can't
control the other you are done
more in winning read it there you go
thoughts encounter
i mean dude this guy's got credibility
galore because this is exactly what
michael jordan did year in and year out
i mean this is what tim grove is known
for working with mj what do you think
it's kind of weird
do you think conor is done yes as an
elite mma fighter there's absolutely no
question you cannot even make the
argument that he's not
it's impossible to make that argument i
think dana white has a real problem
because he doesn't really have a stable
of stars
outside of conor mcgregor that's why
they keep doing what they're doing i
mean
have you guys ever been to a live ufc
fight i mean the energy
is just simply off the charts i've been
to two title fights in vegas
absolutely i went well my friend is ryan
bader so he fought twice once he fought
jon jones and then he fought oh he lost
he lost both of those unfortunately but
he's doing great in bellator
but dana white has a problem he doesn't
have any stars now it's not going to
hurt the business they just brought in
175 million dollars from a crypto
company for their biggest sponsorship
everlasting but you know what conor
mcgregor is the next
wait for it ronda rousey that's all he
is right now he's nothing more
he's nothing more than that his next
bigger than ronda rousey no no timeout
no he
in the mma he's not his next fight is
going to be
against jake paul because it'll be for
nine figures easy
dana white will eventually get behind it
and have to promote him i think that's
why he keeps him relevant
in ufc so he can sanction that fight but
you know what
that's the one i'd watch i'm not
interested in watching connor fight in
the ufc anymore
he's not at that level he's not at the
elite league it's funny you brought up
something last week when you said look
if there's ever a time
that dana white makes a phone call to
dustin poirier and says look here's
there's a couple bucks take this hit
that clearly didn't happen he didn't get
that phone call first of all
i like the approach uh connor took with
the fight he started with the kicks i
like the way he started the fight but
the moment he went on the ground gerard
was saying this yesterday
this guy to to learn how to wrestle and
and be on the ground i mean you have to
learn how to
get out of it for four minutes he was
stuck and dustin wasn't even pounding
this guy
he wasn't even distribute what happens
when you're down there is you're going
to lose all the stamina
you can't last when you get the moment
he got up the last 15 seconds i don't
know if you saw that or not
the 15 seconds when he got up did you
see his energy did you see like he was
he was done like he didn't have the
energy anymore which means
stamina is a problem i told the guys my
prediction was if conor wins he wins in
the first round
if it goes past first round dustin wins
no question by the way if he wouldn't
have broken his leg
his ankle say that wouldn't happen to
his ankle i think we got the [ __ ] kicked
out of him and
it would have been done and it's even
worse and he's a bloody mess but you
know what his strength you know
his success came from his feet so if he
can't
have that as a weapon anymore i mean
he's broken his leg twice now
with kicks so i mean his number one
strength has gone completely neutered
from him
so there's no way he can compete at that
level because he's not a boxer or a
wrestler let me tell you something
you you brought up a good point here
that i don't know where ufc goes from
here because i would
i would i would call myself a casual fan
meaning i don't know much about ufc
but if conor mcgregor's fighting i'm
going to watch it
now without conor i don't know who i
would give two shits about i don't think
about this i get that i'm just saying me
i wouldn't go yeah
let me tell you why you're going to
watch it here's why you're going to
watch okay
never underestimate the power of a dana
white so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye